this woman is obviously having a mental
health breakdown i stopped the video i
was like absolutely not this is not a
mental health breakdown this is a temper
tantrum that is consciously being thrown
by an adult she is using emotion to
manipulate the people around her into
getting sympathy people think if they
yell and scream and cry loud enough that
it'll the focus will be on calming the
person down instead of what they did and
sometimes it works
well that's the thing too it's like
people want to throw the the mental
health thing out all the time in five
four three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain or should i call it the genius
bows nah this is the genius leak because
i'm about to leak everything
yo we look like we're about to rob
somebody we should
well it might be mostly me but we do no
actually
we look like we're up to something but
that's that's exactly how every show
should start right we are up to
something it's like i'm a [ __ ] ninja
and i just ended my day and i just
started like slowly unpacking my [ __ ]
how have you been dude i've i've been
good man i feel like i've been coming on
this show for a hot minute it's been
like over three years hasn't it so it's
been a hot second yeah everyone watching
i feel like y'all if you've been
watching for me you've been seeing me
out every season in my life now that i'm
not working corporate i got the
sunglasses and the hat on that's right
you're not working corporate anymore
you've been doing a lot of like murder
mystery [ __ ]
yeah by the way i had no idea how [ __ ]
up this world is
like there's so many [ __ ] crazy
stories like i've been i started
watching some of your stuff and kind of
keep it in the background and a part of
me turns it off sometimes because like i
don't want to listen this before i go to
sleep because that [ __ ] me up
don't go to sleep don't go to sleep keep
binge watching my videos okay that [ __ ]
[ __ ] me up it's so crazy yeah and i
mean like honestly david it's really
hard because going through the cases and
reading all of the information because
sometimes i pick a case and then we end
up not covering it and so i've just
ingested all of this crazy stuff and i'm
like okay on to the next [ __ ] up thing
but i mean the cool thing is too some
parts of my job i'm do right now i'm
doing a lot of um less murder stuff i do
the murder stuff like on my youtube and
my twitch which sounds really weird but
then um some of the other stuff has been
like uh like i got that wait i don't
know if i should say it i got a tv show
on a big network it's not like my own
show but i'm like featured on it in like
a whole bunch of episodes and um it's
kind of more like watching like cctv
footage of crimes that are happening and
i just get to crack jokes or like i do
this like safety app where like you
heard a citizen dude
citizen i have it on my phone that's
like halfway past time oh yeah yeah so i
do like i do like the live announcements
there so like if it's like man stabbed
on pico like it'll pop up and it'll be
like good morning los angeles a man was
stabbed today on pico boulevard but
don't worry we've got all of your
updates here safety we're figuring out
where he's going let's listen to the
radios and like i get to just like
listen to ditch patch and figure out all
that dude citizen that you know what's
even better than citizen app [ __ ]
just the the neighborhood app i thought
you were about to do a uh
an ad read no i was like neighborhood
app no the neighborhood app no david we
can't talk about that [ __ ]
we can't talk about that when i want
here yeah got the video
all right but that's the other thing you
know what though i will say
it's nice to feel safe but i get scared
looking at those abs because it'll be
two o'clock in the morning and it'll be
like baby walking down the street alone
like
what yeah this isn't that big [ __ ]
wild neighborhood app is just the
neighborhoods talking like the neighbors
talking [ __ ] because people kind of like
watch out for each other but the
funniest thing about the neighborhood
app is it's like there are some people
that are so [ __ ] racist they don't
even know that they're racist oh my god
like what so
like i still have the neighborhood app
in the area that i used to live in right
it's it's it's like south pasadena is
pretty affluent and so somebody will
write some [ __ ] and you know this person
is just trying to say one [ __ ] word
but doesn't want to they're like okay
guys i want you to be careful there were
some people out looming in front of my
place and somebody was like oh what do
they look like uh they're they're uh
taller
uh short haired um baggy clothes
darker complexion black just say black i
was like wait you're gonna get to the
thing it's gonna be the thing it's
that's always always always if somebody
writes that was me i'm your [ __ ]
neighbor you're kidding me you're joking
and you see people just [ __ ] like yo
what the [ __ ] was that about i'm your
i've been here for five years i'm your
[ __ ] neighbor
and they're like yo what are you talking
about and they started like okay well
there were some other people there like
the other day he goes those are my
[ __ ] kids like what are you talking
about
it reminds me you know what that reminds
me of of this story of this guy he was a
black dude that he was walking up to his
apartment in new york or something and
this drunk lady this was from a while
back she's just like where's your key
and he's like excuse me and she's like i
just want to make sure that you actually
live here and he tries to like get into
the building because he lives there and
now he's mad because there's this like
white lady that's just for no reason
make asking him for proof that he lives
there so what would you do wouldn't you
just push through excuse me yeah i'd be
like get the [ __ ] out my way yeah you
wouldn't show her the key right y'all
wouldn't show her the key right you just
push through and so she's
no i'm not letting you in here and i've
been loving watching the karen videos
because they all have the same mindset
did you see the victoria's secret karen
no
oh is this the one that was like a
teacher too yes oh my god david j you
watch that right it's so bad it is one
of the craziest things i've ever seen
and like you know i was i was streaming
it and i was talking about it and people
were like bose this woman is obviously
having a mental health breakdown i
stopped the video i was like absolutely
not this is not a mental health
breakdown this is a temper tantrum that
is consciously being thrown by an adult
she is using emotion to manipulate the
people around her into getting sympathy
people think if they yell and scream and
cry loud enough that it'll the focus
will be on calming the person down
instead of what they did and sometimes
it works
well that's the thing too it's like
people want to throw the the mental
health thing out all the time like in
those like manipulative situations right
because it's so weird because if you try
to apply that in other situations it
doesn't seem to work like for example
like with simone
four-time olympic champion right she
takes this break for mental break and
[ __ ] but they're like oh that's not an
excuse wait fill me in on that because i
wasn't so you know simone
i don't want to mispronounce her last
name
bile simone biles right so she was
supposed to compete um
and she said she just can't do it i
don't know the specific i'm pretty sure
there's more stuff that came out later
on but she wanted to take a mental break
she's like she can't do it yeah and so
people started ripping into her on
twitter and social media platforms
saying like you're letting your team
down it's selfish you're weak how can
you call a four-time
olympic gold medal this week who the
[ __ ] do you think you are talentless
critics that's what it is like really
truly it's amazing right it's amazing
but the funny thing is like you go back
to that karen video right mm-hmm but
mental health is an excuse for her this
person who's a [ __ ] degenerate oh my
god that's so true big facts david and
that hurts me right
i just i'm like do people see themselves
in certain people and because they can't
see themselves in simone biles they
don't want to empathize for her you know
it
like
people are realizing how powerful their
words are and how they can just say the
right thing and just get whatever they
want and it's not really even what they
mean half the time anymore yeah and by
the way too
sonny lee also on our team one [ __ ]
gold so it's all good really oh okay
it's weird because people look at this
olympic team as if simone biles is the
only talented person on that whole
[ __ ] team
there are other people on that team that
can stand the [ __ ] up it's a team thing
so what are you talking about right now
it's ridiculous like people were going
in they called her lazy like okay
imagine and this is why i like i try to
envision sometimes imagine this twitter
person that's like you're lazy
ungrateful un-american i'm sure that
came out at some point and they they
pictured themselves having a one-on-one
conversation with simone biles but now
imagine you're having that one-on-one
conversation with her in person but the
whole olympic team is lined up there too
and they're listening to you [ __ ] out
simone but they're like excuse me sir we
we're here we we've been training all
year like we got this yeah and they're
like not even thinking about who the
[ __ ] are you fighting for like who
you're not fighting for the team you're
not fighting for simone you're not
fighting like what is this for it's for
you also too why are you guys acting
like you actually give a [ __ ] about the
olympics
like you've never talked about the
olympics all year
at all yeah none of these sports and all
of a sudden is super important to you
like calm the [ __ ] down that's the thing
about the internet right like everybody
feels like they have to have an opinion
about something at all times and you
really don't sometimes you could just
shut the [ __ ] up just close the window
just close just close the browser window
i don't i don't understand it's like you
make a conscious choice to either exit
out of this or type a whole bunch of
words that i don't want to read
like
i don't dude i don't really get i think
because i have a smaller audience i
don't really get a whole lot of um
crazy stuff in my world but like
occasionally i read some dumb [ __ ] like
i had a guy the other day that was
defending a guy that killed four people
in a supermarket and he goes on this
whole thing about like you know people
have mental health problems this guy
didn't know how to reach out first of
all you're def defending a killer and
then the second line was him talking
about how adolf hitler was misunderstood
and i was like okay we're we're done i'm
just you know what i did i closed the
window yeah that's that's exactly what i
did i don't agree with this person i
close the window i go make food i do
some sit-ups i touch grass i go outside
well yeah well it's because a lot of the
times when you when you get to control
what you have in your world people say
you're weak they go oh my god you're so
what are you scared it's like or i could
just click
the [ __ ] off oh my gosh or like oh you
that reminds me too of like you probably
haven't seen this too too much but have
you seen the people on twitter when they
get really mad about a situation and the
creator either glazes over it or their
response isn't good enough and then
everyone's like
address it
i see it all over because i'm on twitch
a lot it's all over the minecraft
communities and there will be like a
little thing that somebody apologized
for like two years later and they're
like i dress it oh my god that's
hilarious
i'm sorry but address it it's just it's
so funny i mean people are just mad
entitled to like your personal
information you know i think something
that blew my mind was so there was a
youtube scandal about three years ago
that really really blew up i want to be
like too specific about what it was but
it was about like somebody like leaving
this group and there was all this stuff
swirling about why it happened and i was
reading some of it and then one day i'm
chilling with some people that are kind
of in the youtube sphere and they're
like oh do you know why so and so left
and my nosey ass is like no why why'd
they leave
[Laughter]
so i and i i get they start telling me
and i'm just like
really no way i don't believe that yeah
they give me more details and more and
more details not a [ __ ] trace of what
actually happened was ever online and i
i was just eating all up like trying to
see does anyone know does it i mean
maybe now but like for months and months
after that and that was the moment that
i knew we don't know [ __ ] about what
happens behind closed doors with these
things never there's there's ndas
there's alliances there's secrecy
there's you know people have dirt on
other people so you know certain people
don't want to say something somebody
kind of starts a war and then the other
person knows this could end really badly
and then one person has the common sense
to pull out whereas other people might
like persevere i'm not talking about
anything specific i'm talking about
youtube in general look [ __ ] in
general yeah but like truly i
that's what was mind-blowing to me is
you never know what's going on and the
stuff that gets out into the public holy
[ __ ] it's not even 20
like we heard so much about like that
shane dawson jeffree star scandal and
all that we don't know anything we don't
know
anything absolutely nothing
like and the only reason some
information started coming out to light
was because there was a whole lawsuit
and it's public information and then
people were getting these bits and
pieces that didn't match up with the
storyline they had created two years ago
and so like the i think the real
interesting part of media is going to be
when like people that
do things and they're not under like
ndas and like non-disparagement and
stuff like that like end up
like well they're not breaking it but
like people don't get contracted in that
way so then later on people leave and
they just start talking all this [ __ ] or
when companies dissolve and the nda is
up and then all the people that are like
involved in it or something like that
like and not everyone's gonna do that
[ __ ] but they're really really reckless
people oh they absolutely will and i'm
gonna watch every second
i sure will like like when those family
channel kids grow up david i'm watching
every video look i'm telling you like i
know stuff about like
for example obviously i'm not going to
say this person's name but there was a
person who was very very famous on the
internet and this person just up and
disappeared everybody had a theory about
why this guy was gone all the time like
this guy has gone there's actually
a few people that i can name that
you guys will never know this
information because it's super personal
or who this person is but this person
actually had a huge huge mental
breakdown
but all the all the theories completely
off
yep completely off and you know me and
only a select few people that know these
individuals actually know what happened
because we know they're family we're
pretty close to them and they don't know
about what why they're gone why they're
missing like this one person like
um had a psychosis thing because uh they
found out that uh
this person was adopted
really didn't [ __ ] know their whole
life didn't know wow and had no idea
either so just that
that shatters your entire reality had no
[ __ ] idea
found out that um he was pretty adamant
about who like who's my mom i want to
know who my mom is right yeah goes and
finds out finds out that
he got adopted and he was let go uh from
his parents because his mom was uh
schizophrenic like pretty severe wow
that that is important to know for your
genetics that [ __ ] him up and it
unlocked the little some [ __ ] in his
[ __ ] head and he went [ __ ] nuts oh
my gosh
thought that god was calling he
it the whole story is so crazy i'm not
going to give too much stuff out but
let's just say this at a certain point
he thought that he was talking to god
and so he was having these weird like
conversations thought he was talking to
god when butt naked climbed up a [ __ ]
mountainside right and i'm talking about
like the mountain sides where the cars
are going through and [ __ ] gets [ __ ]
hit by a car
like a deer
in the middle of the night because he
was screaming calling for god saying
that god is calling him to the mountain
hits him breaks almost every [ __ ]
bone in his [ __ ] body this podcast is
brought to you by liquid death have you
ever walked into one of your local
stores and noticed a random tall boy
beer in the water bottle section well it
was probably liquid death and it's not
beer you [ __ ] dummies it's fresh ass
spring water i love the sparkling water
especially when i'm at a party and i
just be pretending to drink a beer
because these dummies don't know that it
ain't beer baby it's fresh ass liquid
death son and i specifically love the
sparkling water if you're wondering why
liquid death is called liquid death by
the way they actually are trying to
bring death to plastic water bottles
plastics aren't as recyclable as people
think and the majority of the bottles
you recycle end up in a landfill because
it's not profitable for these receiving
plants now check it out basically what's
going to happen is that it incentivizes
them so it guarantees these companies
will recycle the dopamine can that
liquid death is in so to all my brain
farts get free shipping on all water and
merch at liquid death dot com slash
brain that's liquid death dot com slash
brain or grab some at whole foods and
7-eleven
like jesus and then everyone was like i
wonder if he's taking a break
they have no idea that their favorite
youtubers on top of a mountain with like
two [ __ ] limbs hanging on yeah it's
like this [ __ ] almost died uh
because he had a schizophrenic episode
because he found out he was adopting his
mama's kids a friend yeah and dude and
like and it's not even it's not even
roasting y'all for like not knowing
every detail i get nosy about some
youtube [ __ ] and i know that i don't
know every detail frenemies okay you
watch that fall out how okay how much
what percentage of the real frenemies
fallout do you think we really know
you're talking about frenemies uh with
with trisha paytas and uh
that's right frenemies i only glanced
over it a little bit but i saw the clip
of them arguing on the thing and all i
know the only thing i know
is uh i know a little bit about trisha
because there was a video of her i don't
know she had like a only fans or
something she would make it and she had
the worst hit job ever seen in my life
but that's the only thing i remember of
her dude that that was so i heard yo i
heard that they were making like thirty
forty thousand dollars an ad
walked away and not to mention the
channel monetization three four million
views y'all that is
wild and she still she walked away from
it like i mean like yo
i always love when someone's a real ass
person and will walk away from money
to you know
be true to themselves
but
i'd do anything for a hundred thousand
dollars let me tell you okay let me tell
you today let me tell you something you
cut that money in half i'll suck dick
like let's go
let's go i don't give a [ __ ] i could
hate you for life i could i could look
at you with disgust and somebody says
every ad we're getting 30 g's you're my
best friend you're my best friend you're
my best friend and i yo i
that it was wild but like david if you
weren't all caught up on that they had
multiple hour long hours of videos
explaining tick tocks other people
joining in all this stuff about
frenemies this front of me says but
y'all gotta understand like when when
somebody is putting out their commentary
on a situation let's be honest they're
going to drive the narrative they want
do you trust any content creator to
drive a 100 truthful honest narrative
that doesn't just serve them because
yeah what i found out in this fear
is that uh the normal rules don't apply
when you get into some kind of issue
with a person it's no longer you and i
have an issue it's our brands have an
issue and now this issue's tied to my
money it's tied to my ego and it's tied
to my future and i will not back down
and that's the attitude that i encounter
and a lot of people on twitch it's how i
see that [ __ ] a lot i have completely
almost separated from twitch groups but
you know youtube groups i yo david you
know i've been through some [ __ ] in this
fear like i
one of the biggest lessons i taught
myself is to never join a pre-formed
group again um because like and i'd like
i'll be honest you know the past ones i
was in those people had relationships
over five or seven years another group
people had relationships for five years
and plus and i'm just now coming into it
i'm fresh new me and i'm a very
opinionated ambitious person and when
you're new into something like that you
have to keep your head down you have to
keep your head down you have to keep
your individuality to a minimum and i
just can't do that [ __ ] but now if i'm
making a hundred thousand dollars a
month that's different that's different
i shut the [ __ ] up i'll shut the [ __ ] up
100k i don't talk i'll read the script
just hand me the script i want to talk
you just tell me what you need me to say
but david for 50k i wouldn't do it for
50k no i wouldn't do it half that money
half it again
hand me the script hand me the [ __ ]
script
i'll be quiet i'll say whatever it's
like david you have to apologize for
everything that you've done 100k let's
go i am sorry i am so sorry for
everything like i i saw we i think i
might have talked about this a while ago
but i remember hearing um because i used
to work on a lot of like podcasts like
back in the day and like ad sales and
touring i remember hearing that
sometimes people needed like group
therapists that go with them like on
tour there's a very i i feel like i
think this is actually written online so
i think i can say it i think i read an
article one time that metallica didn't
get along for the last decade or two and
so they had a a person that was like a
counselor that if there were disputes
they had to mediate [ __ ] while they were
on the road but these people stick
together and write it out for the money
but my minimum is 100k that's correct
you know what's so interesting you know
what the most interesting thing about
the whole frenemies thing is is that i
found out that ethan is still in his 30s
that
my shock there i feel like it's so
i think he's like 34 or 33.
no look that [ __ ] up right now look it
up on your phone uh his age oh okay wait
get take a guess write it in the
comments
all right
like i swear wait i'm a guest real quick
no dude there's no i'm gonna say 36.
i think he's like 34 or 35. like he's
young he's young
he's he's 36 on the nose he's a baby
he's youngest but he just turned 36 just
that and he he is he's younger than bart
and joe yeah
really
dude barton joe 37
holy [ __ ] yeah i really don't know
everything going on with these groups i
can't believe they're that old i'm just
kidding
i thought he was in his like late 40s
like ethan no i would have said early
40s but still like i mean i don't know
but it's also but it's not like just
based on like appearance or something
like that it's based on a lot of the
stuff he's accomplished and what he gets
into and the business moves he makes it
all he's just off appearance does this
guy look always fun damn dude i yeah i
would have thought i definitely would
have thought he was a lot older because
they run they do a lot
yeah
i didn't learn for the longest time
um so when i first kind of got into the
youtube sphere i was in smosh so i was
used to big views big advertisements big
this go big go try to go viral
big numbers and for the longest time i
didn't realize how many content creators
get you know a decent amount of like
views and they're running all these
different businesses and things like
that like they're making appearances
they're doing podcasts they're like you
have like food businesses and stuff like
that you're doing like all these deals
and doing all this but like sm even
smaller people they run all these
multiple things and they do really well
yeah whereas it's wild to me that a lot
of times and i i mean i used to do it
too people will look at somebody's
viewership and be like your channel is
failing but they don't understand that
it's because this person has all this
other stuff going on the the the
influencer culture is kind of becoming
like an entrepreneur culture if you know
what you're doing yeah i mean a hundred
percent like i i think it's it's about
who's a lot more smarter with their [ __ ]
and then who's not right
so i know certain people who numbers
aren't that great but they don't give a
[ __ ] because they when they were popping
they've already established themselves
and they could literally do whatever the
[ __ ] that they want and that's the level
that i'm trying to get on it's like okay
i've done so well to the point where i'm
literally gonna cancel myself
because that is how i retire i'll cancel
myself boost the views on all my other
videos and then it's funny because the
public sits there and they're like oh
you fell off oh you're irrelevant oh
this and it's i this was funny i saw
somebody because remember i said i'm
really into like the twitch and
minecraft sphere all the drama i've seen
over there david you wouldn't believe it
you would have a breakdown but i saw
this minecraft kid that had like 20 000
followers or so but she had a really
popular fan base and she was getting
like five or six thousand likes on each
one of her tweets and she posted wow
never thought i'd see the day that my
tweets get more likes than jeffree star
and she like posted the screen cap and i
was like [ __ ] he makes a million
dollars a week you you when you make a
million dollars a week with your 5 000
likes you come back here you come back
but isn't it sad what the what their
value of themselves is is based on
tweets it's like oh i am now a valuable
person oh it's like funny you gonna
realize when you getting all them likes
and you still hate yourself in a year
you gonna learn that's well that's the
thing too like you that's why you see
now
a lot of creators they come in hot and
they disappear real fast they can't
handle this [ __ ] number one is because
they thought that they wanted to be
famous they thought being famous is a
goal in life and it's not yeah being
famous is not a goal it's like what are
you creating what is your what is your
future what are your next steps and
this space too people envy fame like
what the [ __ ] is so dope about fame like
you have no privacy at all everything
that you do is [ __ ] scrutinized
people hate you one day they love you
the next you have to have enough mental
clarity and strength to withstand that
on a daily [ __ ] basis what is so
great about fame the cool thing about
being famous is the the
that should be the effect that you have
after you do something great you are
recognized for doing something that you
truly like and care about when you do
stuff just for fame you end up like that
person right where you tweet something
as [ __ ] sad as i never thought that
one day my tweets would get more than
jeffree star oh my god that made me that
one made me i was like oh my sweet
summer child jeffree star was in a lot
of controversy too right yeah oh but i
mean honestly he stepped away from all
of it and said i'm getting a farm i'm
getting a yak he literally bought a butt
i swear to god this makeup billionaire
girl he's probably not a billionaire but
i mean not that far off this definitely
one of the richest youtubers i mean yeah
he said [ __ ] all this i'm out i'ma go
buy a farm in wyoming and get a bunch of
yaks and he really does like post on his
instagram now these are all my beautiful
yeah get the [ __ ] out of here
he's living the life that that's like
some dave chappelle and then meanwhile
some 17 year old minecrafter is
comparing themselves like they're better
than jeffree star and i'm like you
come on this [ __ ] cashed out i i
think you know what you were saying
before it's like why do people envy
famous people why do they want to be
famous i remember and i i might have
talked about this on geniusbrain before
but when i first kind of started getting
into this i wanted to be popular because
i thought that if a lot of people liked
me then i would like myself or like it
was like oh i get to show everyone look
at all these people that like me but it
does nothing for you because the reality
of it is when you get to a certain level
you're no longer a person you're an
entity they call it the entitization of
content creators so you are behind the
surface whereas you have this other kind
of internet persona that's like a
heightened version of yourself and
everyone loves that persona or they hate
it but you're a different person so
you're not even feeling all that love
that you thought you were gonna get
because it doesn't feel real yeah and
i've you know i've dealt with that i've
definitely felt that a lot that
sometimes i'm just an entity that's why
i love being on like shows like yours or
like going on like you know some of my
homies shows i just go on like for free
and chill because i like being myself
sometimes yeah you know um that's the
hard thing too it gets to the point too
where a lot of influencers don't they
don't even know what themselves is like
like who the [ __ ] are you yeah and then
no no so this is something that happens
with the minecrafters you would probably
find this really interesting there are
these minecraft kids that join like
they'll be like you know they might have
50 000 followers then one day they join
a huge server like do you know who dream
is he's a massive minecraft youtuber he
gets like like 30 million views per
video or something like god damn yeah so
he's got this minecraft server it's
called like dream smp and it's like the
peak of minecraft everyone that's on
that channel is getting millions of
views like five to thirty million views
they're all popular they have these
rabid fan bases and everyone dreams of
being in this group well i saw some
people that recently got admitted and
over less than a year they all went up
to 900 000 followers a million followers
on twitter but now they're locked into
this huge diverse brand of the only
thing in common with these million
people is i like minecraft they all have
different opinions they all want
different content they're all going to
be different people in a year they like
different music they like different
outfits they like different things so
now you have this massive platform with
a million followers but everyone [ __ ]
hates you randomly like it it you can't
control your audience so when you reach
that level of fame you have no choice
but to strip it down you you can't be
yourself there so then you feel confined
to be this image that makes everybody
happy and those people i've noticed
don't seem very happy i would rather
take the audience i have which really
isn't smaller i have a very large
audience i feel like for like what i do
and what i've built and i'm sure i'm
very very happy with my people are kind
of like me because i didn't go for any
crazy growth i've never been anyone that
i wasn't and like i oh oh my god i just
smiled a little bit thinking about my
community it's so nice it's so nice you
know that's the cool thing too is like
being yours is probably kind of like
that too like being able to create
content by being yourself is a very good
and strong foundation because no matter
what you do you just go back to the
source right it's like why am i doing
this it's because of this reason because
i know who i am see
i definitely understand that that stage
of like not knowing where you're at and
where you want to go right that's the
feeling that i [ __ ] hate i never want
to feel that again i know what i want in
life like i want to just create and just
do [ __ ] that makes me happy right so
whenever like bose wants to do something
she goes you down i was like sounds fun
if it sounds fun i'm down that's really
about it i don't really need much
incentives after that yeah yeah it just
i just need to enjoy the [ __ ] process
and that's all i [ __ ] need right now
and the hard part too once again when we
talk about that idea of [ __ ] identity
when you don't know who you are you
always bend to everybody else's will no
matter where you [ __ ] go yes and you
become this [ __ ] sorry ass people
pleaser and nobody can [ __ ] trust you
nobody knows who the [ __ ] you are
because you don't know what you want so
you don't know what to look what
opportunities to look for yeah that that
is something that i noticed about myself
i recently started traveling like after
i got my vaccines i i usually do my
streams on sundays and mondays watch my
stream sundays and mondays okay
but so then tuesdays through saturday i
had free time so i just started
traveling i just started buying a
one-way ticket somewhere i'd get a hotel
room somewhere and just have fun i went
to florida i went to san diego i went to
napa valley i went to virginia i went to
new york and i loved the freedom to
travel and do whatever the [ __ ] i wanted
and i said oh my god how do i continue
to keep up this lifestyle well i need to
make enough money to do it and i need to
always have an open and flexible
schedule and now that i know what i want
every opportunity i seek has to give me
an open and flexible schedule and it has
to give me enough money to do the things
that i want i don't need this much i
just need you know this much and because
i know the direction i want to go i'm
able to seek out those opportunities if
you don't know where you're going or who
you are
everything's just going to keep passing
you by cause you're gonna be like is
that it hello my friends my wonderful
brain farts this podcast is brought to
you by ipvanish if you don't know what a
virtual private network is that means
you are browsing the internet not in a
safe manner people web snoopers are all
up in your business and i'm not judging
anything you do while you're looking
online but that's your business and your
data ipvanish will help you circumvent
any online censorship and get protection
when using public wi-fi so basically
nobody can see what you're doing online
as it should be so go to ipvanish.com
brain claim your 65 savings their annual
plan is just 44.99 for the first year
with our exclusive discount this is the
time to sign up with our discount and
their current promotion you can get a
vpn for 65 off the usual offering
ipvanish is the best of the best even
rated 4.7 out of 5 on trustpilot and
that's with more than 6 000 reviews
remember it's ipvanish.comrain
to get the deal and start protecting
yourself online
is that it yeah yeah yeah yeah is that
it and you just don't know but whereas
like when you see something that you
like you're like yeah i want that yeah i
want that and i do that same [ __ ] and
like isn't that crazy though do you ever
like take a step back and just look at
how your life is right now and then you
go back to bose of 10 years ago like
could you imagine your life being like
this and you know i was talking about we
were just talking about this off off the
podcast which is something that you know
i really resonate with now is that when
you see people in life who have worked
hard for what they have now they are the
most grateful people when you are given
things and you never had to work for it
it's hard to be grateful for you see
these like in celebrity kids all the
time right they
they kind of just have things and they
you see them how how reckless they are
with all the stuff that are given to
them because it's just a given they
never had to work for it yeah there's
nothing for them to look back and
reflect and say oh you know what like
the david of 10 years ago is so
different now and the things that i
didn't have before i have now right and
it makes me feel really good like just
even something small i got a swing on a
tree outside
yo let me tell you something your boy
never had a swing on a tree before yo
sometimes we do little things for our
inner child our old self and it feels
[ __ ] good it feels great yeah i do
stuff from little me all the time like
what you want what you want little bones
you want you want this keyboard you want
this piano let me get two baby let me
get two keyboards i don't even know how
to play it at all i don't give a [ __ ]
well that's why i bought all these shoes
when i first started making money
because i was so [ __ ] poor everybody
around me that were drug dealers and
[ __ ] we're having all this nice [ __ ] i
couldn't sell drugs i was too much of a
[ __ ] i wanted to sell drugs so [ __ ]
bad and i would have been so [ __ ]
good you really did because your toe
went
out
of selling drugs that's actually you
know i don't have much regrets one of my
biggest regrets i should have sold
at least once yeah
i just wanted to do it because the way
they were doing it the system was all
[ __ ] up they weren't maximizing their
profits i'm like you guys suck ass and
you're getting high on your own supply i
would have been so [ __ ] good yeah
dude i never i never sold drugs either
you would have been great i just gave
them away
[Laughter]
hates you i was like what the [ __ ]
where's my split it's like i just gave
it away
i thought we were selling happiness he
was having a bad day man people are
people man smoke this
he would have been killed so fast oh my
gosh seriously yeah yeah i just bought
all these [ __ ] jordans i remember
because like as a kid i wanted these
[ __ ] shoes and it felt good then i
found out that material [ __ ] don't even
make me that happy yeah but you have to
experience it to know
you really do and and you know i uh
when i first like last year i moved into
a really nice apartment nice ass place
okay and i you know it's kind of
expensive but you kind of have your own
non-negotiables and like i learned that
i don't spend a lot of money on like
clothes or like um just like certain
things i just don't i spend my money on
travel in my environment but it's
because i need to wake up every day and
know that my life is different than it
was five years ago if you don't make
those upgrades if you if big things
happen in your life you get a 30 000 you
know raise or something like that or you
move to a new job you get that cause
look ain't nobody just giving out thirty
thousand dollars each day you know what
i mean but i wish when yeah when big
things happen in your life you want to
change the environment and the scenery
to show yourself that things have
changed so when you bought all those
shoes you got to look at them and be
like oh this is new david and then you
also slowly got to be like i don't
really need this anymore let me go make
a new goal because otherwise you're
going to sit there wishing for it let me
ask you this though yeah do you ever
feel guilt when you buy [ __ ]
um
sometimes i'll be spending a lot of
money david
yo i what what is that
dude sometimes i just be swiping the you
know i got that you know i got that
heavy a mix bro
giraffe don't mind if i do
i really be
i'd be spending some money david but
sometimes i do it because like i'll i'll
go on a trip and spend a couple grand
but then i'll come back and bust my ass
and book stuff that i wouldn't normally
book and then make all that money back
times too whereas if i didn't spend it i
would have just said no and laid in bed
so like
you're [ __ ] funny joe do you is that
crazy of me i feel mad guilt when i buy
[ __ ] oh i feel none david i feel none in
fact i you know as i pulled up i just
gave somebody my card and i was like go
swipe it while i'm going
i feel mad guilt like i feel like this
weird thing of like when i buy something
like i'm i'm about to well this is also
for work too but i'm going to hawaii in
a couple of weeks right and i feel
guilty
like i'm looking for like the cheapest
hotel that barely has any air air
conditioning running and i'm like you
know what you're just going to sleep
there anyways you're going gonna go out
and then i feel this like mad [ __ ]
guilt that i'm that i even have the
opportunity to buy things that i feel
like i know i deserve but at the same
time i feel like i don't deserve it's
weird like i feel guilt whenever i buy
something new i feel guilty unless
there's a utilitarian purpose for it
right so i'll buy these chairs right
these chairs are really [ __ ] nice but
it's for the podcast so i feel better
like if i do something for my soul like
for my mental health i feel you [ __ ]
[ __ ] how dare you i see you're wild for
that i actually just recently one of the
other projects i'm working on is music
i've been working on music for like uh a
hot minute i think i probably even i
feel like i had to have talked about it
at some point here but um i just finally
got hooked up with these really awesome
like grammy-nominated producers they
told me how much the track is gonna be
and i was like great let me get two and
this shit's very expensive but it's my
passion project it's for me it's for my
inner child it's knocking it off the
bucket list and that to me is invaluable
as [ __ ] you know let me just tell you
that was the most baller sentence i've
ever heard of my life this [ __ ] said i
just missed him grab me nominate
producers i said how many tracks you got
two swipe it up [ __ ] flexed on me
super hard let me tell you my situation
been like this i missed some two grammy
night grammy nominated producers they're
like how much is i said hold on let me
hit up my homies first see what i was
thinking let me see y'all take royalties
i said no let me own i want to own
everything on it what kind of music you
you about to do industrial doom metal
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is that this girl
odd as [ __ ] by the way before she came
here she was like david i'm about to eat
some chicken skin in my bed i'll hit you
back
she
up
she said she was gonna eat chicken
skinned are better than head over yo who
the [ __ ] says that cause that's what i
was doing i was like yo let me eat this
chicken skin real quick and then i'm
gonna be [ __ ] he's chicken skin this
[ __ ] rich that's that's rich people
[ __ ] really chicken skins
that's either poor people [ __ ] or rich
people yeah and we have no idea
no middle class [ __ ] only these
chickens can either you broke as [ __ ]
are you rich as hell yeah and then also
the in bed part it's like i have no idea
of this woman's status
oh is she depressed like what's going on
no i'm living my best life dude no it's
just the sentence is so [ __ ] odd what
is what you call a doom scrap metal what
the [ __ ]
doom uh so okay here's my thing david i
okay this is gonna sound so corny but
like it really is a pattern a lot of the
stuff that i've done in my career that
has worked out really well has been very
innovative i'm i think i'm pretty sure
i'm the first truecom live streamer
pretty much ever that's been doing it
for this long and and had some success
in it the genre does not exist after i
i've been doing it for about five years
now it just picked up about three months
ago it's so funny it really kind of blew
up on twitch around june uh doing some
true crime live streaming random people
picking it up but back in february
livewire posted an article that said how
erica bozeman claimed true crime on
twitch i've been in this [ __ ] for a
minute you know when i see a hole in the
market i want to feel it so for example
to me and this is going to sound so
boring but i'm just going to tell you
how my brain works to me doom metal is a
type of music that involves like these
kind of mathematical riffs that are
really interesting on the guitar and
they resonate very well with people that
have adhd because you never know what
the next note is going to be it's an
older style of music it was really
popular around like the 80s a sludge
metal and then around the earth like
late 90s early 2000s that genre of music
doesn't really exist anymore but there's
something about those riffs so to
modernize it i want to take that old
style of music and turn it into an
industrial format which would be more
like that electronic sound that kind of
thing this sound doesn't really exist
right now and i want to create it and i
love to do stuff like that because i
have a vision um and my goal honestly
david i don't know if you're the same
way about this my goal is to entertain
people i love it it is my ultimate
passion that people enjoy what i'm
putting out seeing commercial success in
an idea i have is something that truly
fuels me and to see people happy and
enjoying it it's all i [ __ ] care
about it's never been about me it's
always been about do you like it okay
great i'm gonna keep going and so my
goal is to always create new unique
experiences that people love and i'm
always coming up with new ideas
damn you're [ __ ] intense i am intense
i know you know what it is no but that's
a really good thing because i i talk
about this too when people say like how
do you become successful in
entertainment like that's the attitude
that you love what you do you you need
that attitude i sadly don't have that
like i i
i don't cause i'm more like i'm doing
this for me you don't like it you're
[ __ ] dumb
you know which is you know it's a good
and a bad thing yeah you know what i
mean because it kind of keeps my sanity
but you're naturally so entertaining on
a massive level you know so it works out
but i have some of those vibes too about
like i'm gonna be me [ __ ] you but like i
i i'm gonna
i don't know you definitely think some
next level [ __ ] because also too like
the you're like five foot nothing but
the amount of knowledge in that little
cranium of yourself
is nice [ __ ] ridiculous like i don't
know how you store [ __ ] in that [ __ ]
head of yours you make me feel dumb
cause you're i bet you read everything
on a page don't you you know what i do i
go i read something i go three word
three words skip ten sentences three or
and then i forget all the details but
you know what david i i hope you can
also see like why that mentality has
caused me so many problems in my life
because when i especially if i hop on a
project with somebody or i'm doing
something i'm looking so far ahead that
i'm annoying okay in a group setting i'm
not gonna lie that [ __ ] is probably
annoying because i got ideas and i'm
like telling you why it's a good idea
like you know something like that and i
get it but when i'm working in my own
world i get to do everything and i get
to call these shots and i don't have to
prove to anyone whether something's
going to work or not i just do it and
then it works they look at your level of
success though like it some people just
function better on their own i have yeah
i have not been a group project person
very well unless i'm taking a back back
back seat i'll show up i'll do my job
you guys do whatever i'll walk away
that's why jk news always worked well
for me i didn't have to do [ __ ] i just
walked up yeah i did joke joke joke made
it really fun and i walked off if it
required for me to think about the
future of the business then we have a
different situation because then it's
like there might be some head butting
you know what i mean but that's why i
have my own thing i continue to do my
own brand i continue to do everything
else because i need my space where i can
create where nobody else can [ __ ]
hold me down yeah because it's
exhausting it really is and and you have
a vision and you're very individualistic
and something uh something people don't
really talk about is when you're in a
group you lose some of your
individualism of course you have to you
have to walk in that unit and oh when i
feel my individualism leaving me i feel
trapped i feel scared i feel an angry
annoyed but i think that's also why we
work well together because like even
with the shows and stuff y'all better
come to our shows
you you kind of let me take the lead on
it but also you trust me and you see
that i know what i'm doing like i've
booked these shows before like i know
how all this stuff works and you're just
like yeah do it i'll show up and i'm
like thank you
you know like i well there has to be a
level of trust right like
if it was some person that i didn't know
i know you now i've known you for years
i know that when you want to do
something you make [ __ ] happen i know
that i don't have to worry right so it's
like okay if bose is passionate about
this [ __ ] and she needs she just needs
to tell me what she needs for me i'll
get it done because at this point
because we're friends i also know that i
don't want to fail you so if you get
something done i'm going to work just as
hard as my end just to make sure that it
happens because at the end of the day
it's like i like i said it has to be fun
yeah if i'm not making it fun then it's
not going to [ __ ] work so if you're
going to if you brought the project to
me and you're like hey this is what it's
going to be i'm like all right let's do
it like i've done it you've already
shown you've already shown what you can
do so what's the point why am i going to
sit here and try to like crunch numbers
with you it's like why yeah yeah and
like for what and james was like yeah
you know what i love i love when like
whenever we start a genius brand show we
kind of like dabble in different topics
and then when we find the right one
we're just all in like for the past 20
minutes i've been like david
okay i wonder if they can see that too
like when we get really into the zone
you know oh 100 and you know what the
thing is too it's like um
people sometimes ask is like yo why
don't you bring like certain people onto
the podcast it's like well because
podcasting too is also an art form
conversation is a [ __ ] art form just
because some people have interesting
things that happen to them doesn't mean
that they're very good at telling those
stories so you've had some bad guesses
man let me [ __ ] tell you
and listen i have no [ __ ] problem
after the podcast is over saying like
hey most likely this is not going to go
up you're kidding yeah i probably
trashed over like 30 or 40 podcasts and
i've it was in the beginning because i
know like personal friends and stuff and
they're like yo i want to try the
podcasting thing out wait so you said
before if you don't like it you don't
like it but you do care about like how
people tuning in i didn't like it oh
yeah oh okay because i got bored like
i'm falling asleep as this person's
speaking and i'm like dude this was
boring as [ __ ] like even i didn't give a
[ __ ] about it and but then what happened
was like i would start telling their
story for them it's like then why are
you here yeah like i could just do it
with another guest and tell your story
so it's just like
that's the other thing too it's like
where everybody feels like they could do
what somebody else does sometimes and
it's true you can but you can't be
disrespectful in that kind of sense like
it takes some skill like i when i first
started podcasting i'm way i'm a way
better podcaster now than i was when i
first started yeah i'm a lot more
concise i slow down the way that i say
things i could elaborate more i'm a
better storyteller than i was and i
thought i was a good storyteller yeah
you're different than you were a couple
years ago because i remember like when
we did one of our first ones these and i
mean it was good it was great of course
but like your conversation is like
really really like great yo did i tell
you i told you about when i met joe
rogan right this podcast is brought to
you by better help my genius farts if
you haven't focused on your mental
health what are you waiting for you are
tense you are cooped up there are so
many things that you need to sort out in
your head because you pushed it aside
for so long and i used to be just like
you but you have to hop on better help
because i'm telling you right now mental
health and the help that you need is
right around the corner better help will
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
you don't have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room and you can
message your counselor at any time while
setting up weekly video phone sessions
it's super convenient and more
importantly allows you to be in your own
safe and comfortable environment i've
used better help and it was a dope
experience and i still use it till this
day so give it a try you have nothing to
lose and so much to gain this podcast is
sponsored by better help my friends and
my genius brain listeners my lovely
genius farts you get 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com genius so visit
betterhelp.com
genius and get that 10 off and work on
that mental health my friends that's b e
t t e r h e l p dot com slash genius you
meant joe rogan i thought i told you
about that [ __ ] you didn't [ __ ] tell
me you meant joe hey let me tell you
something about this girl all right
she'll be over here [ __ ] meeting
everybody i love and i'm over here just
in my room just jacking off doing jack's
shoes because i invited you to that dave
chappelle show the other night and you
know okay guys guess who was there
bartending tiffany haddish where the
[ __ ] were you hold on a second where
were you this [ __ ] called me i was
drunk as [ __ ] i could not make it yeah
yeah oh yeah okay i'm just saying look i
invited him i did two podcasts back to
back i was blasted like i had not i
could not make it i was like listen i
was sitting there and i was talking to
mario i'm like listen it's like 12. i
need to see these people she goes i
don't even know what you're saying like
in my mind i would say coherent
sentences
she was like you're not going anywhere
i'm like you're probably right that's
that's fair that's absolutely fair but
okay well okay so i'm matt and she
invited me though i did i did i invited
i'd invited david
to a 200 person private chappelle show
like and guess who you know what can i
say this
nah maybe not i'll try to think i mean i
guess i can you know who popped up who
and came on stage and sang a song who
stevie wonder
just
you're [ __ ] lying to me right now
you're saying [ __ ] right now i'm not me
i'm not and i invited you to that show
let me tell you something i invited you
to that show i
i invited you [ __ ] is going on are you
[ __ ] serious
i invited you i sure did so
next time but anyways okay so i gotta
tell you about the joker
so that was in la okay but that was in
la like what was it like a thursday or
friday night or something like that so
the week prior to that chappelle was
doing a whole bunch of shows he did the
joe rogan shows and stuff like that so
i'm at this after party and someone
introduces me to like joe rogan he's
standing there with uh tom segura they
were cool [ __ ] they were really nice and
somehow i get to talking to joe about
like true crime or something and we
ended up talking for like 10 minutes and
a couple minutes into it i'm like wait a
minute does he actually like me or is he
just really good at podcasting and he's
podcasting in real life right now yeah i
think it was the second one but it was
absolutely nice because you're really
good at this [ __ ] now too but that's how
he was he literally when he engaged yo
when joe rogan engages in a conversation
with you you feel like he cares about
every single word he's saying to this
day i don't know if he cared i would
like to assume so but my self-esteem
says no bose he's just really good at
his job
that's [ __ ] he's crazy good he's good
even real good more beyond joe rogan
[ __ ] stevie wonder [ __ ] performed
are you out of your [ __ ] mind yeah i
was so nervous about whether i could see
that but i mean like i didn't sign
anything we just had to put our phones
away but yeah yeah it was really cool
super super cool
you weren't there you went david you
weren't next time next time i invite you
you're gonna come right i'm never
drinking ever again never again
what the [ __ ]
is going on right now that dude i just
pictured stevie wonder and then me
crying
it was a whole lot going on and there
are certain people that i meet like
listen i don't get i don't get star
struck by a lot of celebrities right
honestly if i met dave chappelle
starstruck if i made joe rogan
starstruck
but that's starstruck here there's
people
before i became an adult adult that
affected me and it's usually musicians
like brian mcknight stevie wonder
i meet stevie wonder
i will fix his eyes just so he could see
my face oh my god david that is so dumb
but it's really funny
david oh my god just so he could see me
cry
david oh my god but you know what i
think that's interesting you say that
because i think that people like artists
and um obviously stevie wonder's an
artist dave is an artist
when they instill emotion in us
as especially as kids or teenagers or
something man that bond is huge you know
i know i meant i did a video with sean
stockman from boys to men i still
remember that [ __ ] to the until this day
and i [ __ ] i don't think i washed my
hand for like
a week because he shook my [ __ ] hand
dude and boys to men helped me through
like getting dumped like sadness i know
so many boys and men just from one girl
that dumped me and bright midnight just
because i had their music on [ __ ]
repeat so like their [ __ ] affected me so
much stevie wonder man all the time
i've been building my castle i can't
dude i wish you were at that show with
me now just so i could have seen you cry
when he came out cause none of us knew i
would have cried you would have cried
i feel myself about to cry just because
you couldn't cry there i would have
bawled my [ __ ] eyes oh my god
everybody's like what the [ __ ] is with
this who invited this spot i'm like ah
that is that is really that is funny
dude i you know i'm trying to think i'm
trying to think of who really affected
me when i was growing up and this this
is the dumbest one you're not a crime
person
no
basically so it was have you ever seen
the movie the craft or heard of it it's
a 90s movie with like these like witches
that are in high school and they're all
like kind of goth right loved the movie
when i was growing up always been a
little goth you know whatever and uh for
rusa bulk was like a very popular um
she was uh she was a celebrity that had
you know mass appeal
i'm trying to figure out what i'm trying
to say she was like a ba-list celebrity
that was up there but she had this whole
goth aesthetic and i loved that she was
accepted by hollywood and she looked
like that and so that made me feel more
comfortable to dress and do the things
that i wanted to and so that was kind of
a role model for me as a kid so as an
adult i remember one time i bought
something from her store and then she
followed me on twitter or something like
i tweeted something and then she
followed me on twitter
and i got so nervous i blocked her so
that she wouldn't unfollow me in the
future because i knew it was coming
that is the most self-destructive thing
i've ever heard of my life what the [ __ ]
are you talking about no it was called
self-preservation and this was four
years ago i don't really do stuff like
that that much anymore no preservation
yeah to preserve myself from having a
[ __ ] breakdown date okay she
unfollows you and you die yeah oh come
on if brian mcknight followed you and
then one day you posted something silly
and he randomly unfollowed you like
wouldn't it
oh that would kill me yeah that would
literally [ __ ] kill me yeah so why
not rip the band-aid off yourself listen
i was 25. listen that sounds like some
damage good [ __ ] dude that is the most
damaged [ __ ] i've ever heard about to
my credit i did it a couple years ago
and i've changed a lot in the past year
or two that's [ __ ] funny yeah that'd
be hilar like dave chappelle follows me
and i'ma go no dave
okay i get it now you're right you're
right you're right you're right
are you insane that's that'd be so funny
if she was you were the first person
that wasn't her friend that she was like
you know what today i'm gonna follow a
random stranger and she follows you and
then you go block she goes [ __ ] this i
think i know and i didn't like block i
think i just like did it so that would
unfold like she would unfollow me like i
made it manually unfollow that's what i
did oh my god
i know i know i'm all embarrassed i
thought like for not the person that you
would meet is like chris hansen from to
catch a predator or something oh no oh
god no dude yeah like a true but see
that's the thing though too i feel like
since i've been doing the true crime
thing everyone tries to talk to me about
it or relate to me over it and i'm like
i don't wanna i don't wanna talk about
murder when i'm at dinner with somebody
eating oysters and they think that like
it's the only thing that i like the
coolest thing about your true crime
stuff is that you are saying everything
that i don't have to read like that's
the best part like when you're talking
about your [ __ ] it's like i don't have
to read this i literally don't i could
just hear you talk about it in the way
that i want to hear it and it feels
[ __ ] good so it's just like because
i'm always curious about this stuff but
there's so much data and just jargon
that you have to go through in order to
get to like the good meat of things that
i just don't care but then you just do
it for me you know it's funny too
because so the the
i've been doing true crime for a while
but the new brand that i came up with is
a little bit different because you know
that era from you know two years ago or
so where actually not even that like
three or four years ago um there was all
these commentary channels that learned
they could just critique another
youtuber and get a bunch of views the
downfall of so and so what's wrong with
lilly singh like
like we we did a video around that era
and i saw that people were using these
youtubers a as clickbait and seo and
then b they're putting somebody down and
[ __ ] talking them because it makes
people feel good about themselves and
they're getting all this viewership from
it just from [ __ ] talking to somebody
and i was like why are we [ __ ] talking
these people that just made a mistake
they're creators they move on they do
things you know why don't we talk [ __ ]
about people who did messed up stuff
like murderers murderers deserve to get
talked [ __ ] about so that's what all of
my content is based around talking [ __ ]
about murderers that's what i do all day
i talk hellish [ __ ] about chris watts
jody aries i'm on a first name basis
with this [ __ ] at that point i know a
lot of the prosecutors stayed by state
by name i know why casey anthony got off
and i have a lot of opinions about it
and all i'm doing is talking [ __ ] about
different attorneys and different
convicted killers people that got off
stuff like that and david i love it my
business is not just true crime it's
talking [ __ ] about people who did [ __ ]
up stuff see this is why you and i get
along
the only thing people want to see from
me is me talking [ __ ] sometimes it it
kills my soul because i i get like man
there's a lot of bad people on this
earth yeah or sometimes sometimes people
make a mistake and i don't want to you
know [ __ ] talk them forever but like
when you kill somebody that is not a
mistake when you especially when you
kill four or five people over and over
again [ __ ] you and i want to talk about
that you know there's some crazy you
know when i look back in my like my
childhood in my life and then i see some
of these stories and i'm like judging
these individuals i'm like look at this
[ __ ] over here just killing
people on the street i was like wait i
used to hang out with people like that
that's how we know david times have
changed yeah and dude i'm telling you
this too if you don't believe that
people can change let me just tell you
this funny story right i was at a
wedding
i went to this wedding and there was a
couple of people there that i did not
expect in fact i couldn't even recognize
them came up to me and they're like hey
david how have you been he goes i'm like
who the [ __ ] is this i have no idea who
this guy is i'm looking at their face
and i'm like is this so-and-so and i'm
like bro what the [ __ ] what are you
doing he's like yeah man i was like what
do you do now it's like like i'm a
pharmacist and i'm a pharmacist bro i
literally seen this dude like
pull out a gun and [ __ ] threaten to
cap some money in the [ __ ] like put a
gun to the dude's forehead before
because he stepped on his [ __ ] air
forces like this is this this crazy
human and he's done a lot of other
terrible things too
he was heavily gang affiliated whole
family was getting affiliated right
somehow changed his life
[ __ ] repented reid did ever he's like
trying to make up for everything that
he's done bad wow and he it's a
pharmacist now and the reason why he
changed him he meant he met a girl that
changed his life yeah they gave him an
ultimatum and probably probably given
him notes on different things like this
is what we're not gonna do and this
person changed he didn't kill anybody
all right but we if he we don't know
okay i don't know
from what i've known he hasn't killed
somebody we
don't we didn't say anything
we literally didn't say anything i'm
telling you people can change man like
it's crazy when you see growth in
somebody that even i didn't expect like
i look at him and i'm unrecognizable
well a lot of our i feel like a lot of
the issues that a lot of us cause or
cause are from like past pain quick
emotional triggers for example that air
force think one thing you just talked
about like you know maybe it was a
trigger that was disrespect he didn't
like that from his past and that's how
he handles it now and you ever been
talking to somebody and you can tell
they're not present they're somewhere
else yeah you know he might have felt
like oh you know somebody did this to me
10 years ago and i'm not going to get
disrespected like that again so when
this situation feels similar sometimes
people will overreact it's like their
pain just gets swelled up in huge ways
that's what happened to me for a long
time i deal with a lot of trauma and i
deal with a lot of triggers but i go to
therapy for these traumas and these
triggers and i do it for me because if i
can control my emotional reaction to my
past or situations that remind me of my
past it keeps me from creating new
problems and that's how my life has been
for the last two years and you know
don't don't beat yourself up if you were
very emotional person you know two three
four five years ago but you know
let yourself change so that you don't
continue to walk in those circles and
create the same issues over and over
again hey therapy is the [ __ ] [ __ ]
man i gotta tell you do i we uh
uh marilyn and i and we're gonna talk
about a podcast too where she and i
started couples counseling and [ __ ]
man this [ __ ] my therapist this [ __ ]
be uncovering [ __ ] in my soul that i had
no idea was there and next to you know
i'm just like
what about daddy dude you know she's
like wow about you i didn't know this
was bothering me you know but the cool
thing about therapy and i think like uh
what a lot of people who who haven't
done it is that it's a really safe space
where you for some reason feel like you
could say everything that you wanted to
say no matter how dumb you thought it
made you feel or what you thought and
then you start uncovering little things
like stuff that you always tell yourself
that you don't care about stuff that you
say that um that you're not embarrassed
about but you really are but then you
get to talk to this person and you get
to talk out these feelings and these
thoughts and it kind of uncovers things
that have been bothering you for years
yeah i i go i go i try to go at least
once a month like i basically a while
back during the pandemic i did like a
six three three no it was like three
month intensive where i was going like
every single week i call it intensive
because that's a lot and it was a lot of
[ __ ] money but i was going every
single week to try to heal myself and
get to a good place so now i still check
in like every month or so and she said
something really interesting to me the
other day i said like oh something
something happened but yeah it was weird
and she was like you have to stop saying
weird she's like i don't like that word
i'm like why and she was like when you
say that something felt weird you're not
saying how it felt
what is weird it's just a word that we
use when we feel so uncomfortable we
want to cut it off we label a person
weird we label ourselves weird we say we
feel weird but you have to explore that
emotion and dive in and figure out what
is weird because otherwise you're
cutting off your emotions from yourself
and how you really feel
damn that's just deep yeah
that's the crazy thing too when you
really start to think about the the why
of things and this is stuff that we
choose to ignore all the [ __ ] time
because it's just easier you know it's
like ah i don't really [ __ ] with that
person somebody asks you why and he's
going to eh but there's a reason why
you know sure there's always something
really always the reason why i also
learned that what in my past i used to
be i used to be very quick tempered like
very confrontational very quick to anger
too but what i learned was anger was my
first emotion that protected me from a
lot of other emotions sadness anxiety
hatred a lot of a lot of different
things but i realized anger was the
first layer and so what i started to do
to myself was any time i felt angry i
tried to push through that anger and get
to the other side of what emotion was on
the other side yeah and um that was
really powerful for me because anytime i
feel anger now i find an opportunity to
explore myself a little bit well guys
that wraps up this episode this year was
good brain podcast it's always a good
[ __ ] time dude it's always black and
yellow you dress like [ __ ] lawrence
fishburn right now
[Laughter]
my youtube channel's out when this comes
out i'ma comment on this i'm gonna hit
top comments so i'm gonna need you guys
to come check out my channel i do live
streams on sundays and mondays on twitch
i do court tv on sundays and i do murder
stuff on mondays and i'm talking [ __ ]
both of those days but also i'm
uploading almost daily on youtube now
about four or five times a week damn
that's [ __ ] amazing that you make me
feel like [ __ ] yeah you should all right
i'm just kidding
well i [ __ ] i should have committed to
that as i leaned back and said yeah you
should and you plug into the matrix [ __ ]
well that hurt my feelings it's been
real y'all we'll see y'all next time
peace